un mes después aún no se ha sentado la
polvadera del terremoto de magnitud 7.8
que sacudió Turquía y Siria
seguimos retirando escombros aquí
retiramos entre 200 y 250 toneladas de
escombros aquí cada día
en cereal Banco Mundial estima los daños
en 5,100 millones de dólares más de
50.000 personas perdieron la vida y para
los que quedan se trata de una
emergencia humanitaria en Siria la ayuda
tardó en llegar a Los afectados en las
zonas del noroeste controladas por los
Rebeldes decenas de miles de personas
siguen desaparecidas y cientos de miles
perdieron sus hogares sumándose a los
muchos más serios desplazados por 12
años de guerra en el país
incluso antes del terremoto las
necesidades aumentaban mientras que la
ayuda internacional disminuía pero no
debemos cerrar los ojos ni dar la
espalda al pueblo sirio no podemos
permitir que esta sea una crisis
olvidada
en Turquía la indignación ha aumentado
por la lentitud de la respuesta del
gobierno algunos han descrito Cómo
intentaban sacar a las víctimas con sus
propias manos mientras esperaban la
llegada de los equipos de rescate
mientras se prepara para luchar en las
elecciones de mayo el presidente arduan
ha pedido Perdón
[Música]
debido al efecto devastador de los
temblores a las difíciles condiciones
meteorológicas y a los daños en las
infraestructuras no hemos podido
trabajar con la eficacia deseadan les
pido perdón por ello
Mientras tanto más de 200 personas han
sido detenidas en Turquía por mantener
unas normas de construcción deficientes
que están poniendo aún más vidas en
peligro ante las múltiples réplicas